- For me, like I will crush if Gavin
just takes the fuckin' phone on Instagram,
sign in to my stories and be like,
"What was that meeting about?"
Like the rant I just gave
you and you were like, "Yes."
I can do that at will.
It's kind of stupid.
I mean it's fucking scary, but like,
I don't think people realize
that fucking making content
is literally like the
sprinkles to my reality,
like I do not believe that
anybody that consumes my content
has any true sense that
I spend 15 hours a day
being a CEO of a big company.
(soft guitar music)
- It was canceled,
I have to get to Cincinnati
for some big meetings tomorrow,
so gotta jump on private, not super fun.
So how do you maximize
when you're making an investment?
I hate going fancy and going private
so how am I gonna maximize?
I've got five or six teammates
now from Team GaryVee,
a couple people I haven't
jammed with as much
so bringing Samir, new from the pay team.
Andy and I need some time,
Gavin's always around
so to me one of the important
things to always think about
is when you're put in situations,
how do you maximize, right?
People have a flight
canceled and are like,
"Ugh my flight's canceled."
How do you turn that into
a meetup with your fans?
How do you like schedule
some meetings in the area?
It's why I have first
in line to have data.
I might do random pop ups.
How do you go on FaceTime
with your family?
How do you go on Instagram
Live and start a communication?
Or in scenarios like this
how do you bring your team
and basically I'm gonna have
a two hour meeting right now
on our way to Cincina--
Literally I've taken five team members,
we're gonna have a meeting,
they're gonna land,
go to a hotel, and fly back
tomorrow while I do my thing.
The added expense to
what I was already paying
for the private flight
with the extra seats
made it R.O.Y. positive.
Consistently hack the
norms, all the action,
all the amazing opportunities
in today's' environment
because of the technology advances
are in the things that have
never been done before.
Making shit up, trying new things,
not being crippled by adversity.
"Oh, shit, all flights
in Cincinnati canceled.
"What the hell am I gonna do?"
No, you know, finances
are an advantage of mine,
I can do the private thing.
But its not just that.
Don't be fancy, turn it
into a two-hour meeting.
Maximize every second, every opportunity.
I did that when I had four bucks,
I do it now when I can go private.
Never deviating from the truth,
which is maximizing the
fuck out of every situation
regardless of if its good or bad.
- [Gavin] Yes.
(Gary and Gavin laugh)
- Your meetings, like your
big meeting of the day,
and kind of do like a
daily story around that.
- [Gary] Yeah, I don't
think we can win on Snapchat
without it being first-person.
I don't think its a content
distribution channel.
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- We can't get away with
Snapchat stories the way we
can with Instagram stories.
- Facebook, like this is good,
but it's missing--
- We're just having a meeting
about Snapchat itself.
And that's a good idea,
'cause we're fuckin' up.
- So we said Snapchat is that.
It's taking one person you're meeting with
throughout that week, or that day.
(chuckles)
- I'm listening to you.
- Tell that story and then where DailyVee
currently on YouTube, is
going three, four days behind,
we just make Facebook Stories
the real-time DailyVee.
But like for this,
it should say the time and
who you're meeting with.
- [Taylor] Yeah, and the Facebook reps,
we met with them, and
they even suggested like,
less designed and not like Instagram,
like Instagram is its
own special platform,
where we can do all those right hooks,
but these other two
need to live like that,
like your day-to-day.
- [Gary] What do you mean?
- [Taylor] For highest performance.
- So like this, it's cool,
but I wanna know what time it is
and who you're talking with.
- And what's that?
- This is Facebook stories.
- Okay.
- So cool, we did like this stuff,
but I would say we could
kill that completely.
- Those Facebook stories?
- Yeah. Besides--
- How is Facebook stories going?
- It started, and then its going down,
because we're sort of just replicating it,
and then we do what I
would call "sea-level"
version of creator.
But if we really push, like
if you wanna see what you're,
DailyVee Live is Facebook Stories.
Just trying to think of ways we'll win
if we can actually push people there,
but we need to figure out why we're--
- I do think a way we can do that
is if I, what is hard for
me is going first-person.
What is not hard for me is
them putting camera on me.
- It being like, yeah.
- Mhm.
(background noise drowns out other sounds)
- So like, if we could take this,
and then right when
you're off the meeting,
like what meeting was that,
or what'd you talk about.
- [Gary] What's your biggest
takeaway from your meeting?
That I'm great with.
For me, like I will crush if Gavin
just takes the fuckin' phone on Instagram,
sign in to my stories and be like,
"What was that meeting about?"
Like the rant I just gave
you and you were like, "Yes."
I can do that at will.
It's kind of stupid.
I mean it's fucking scary, but like,
I don't think people realize
that fucking making content
is literally like the
sprinkles to my reality,
like I do not believe that
anybody that consumes my content
has any true sense that
I spend 15 hours a day
being a CEO of a big company.
I met you, you were, how
long have you been at Vayner?
- [Taylor] Two years.
- What have you been with us
on the team for a month or two?
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- Like I bet you it's not
the way you thought it was.
- [Taylor] No. (laughs)
- So teach me what are some of the things
that are different than
you thought it was.
- [Taylor] Being on the team?
- Yes.
Like start with the thing
I'm most fascinated by.
As somebody that's worked in
the company for two years,
and knows that I put out stuff.
You know how I always tell the company,
like I am the CEO of VaynerMedia,
don't be confused.
It's more extreme than you thought, right?
- [Taylor] It's more
extreme than I thought,
and its a lot more like "test
and learn" than I thought.
Like I thought you guys
had like a cadence,
but every day is different.
- Yes.
- [Taylor] And like that's probably
like the most interesting
thing separate from Vayner.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- What do you think?
As somebody who knows
my content, is fannish,
you know like new stuff.
- Yeah.
- Like what's been the biggest things
that are different than
the way you thought it was.
I'm nicer than you thought.
(Samir laughs)
- No.
(Gary laughs)
- I'm meaner.
- I was like, "Oh, what is he like?"
and I was like dude, surprisingly, like,
well not surprising to me, but like.
- Exactly like he is.
- [Samir] You're a good person,
where like all these other people,
like if I'm with the reality,
- Are not.
Like they're not who they say they are.
- I'm aware.
- [Samir] Like I emailed you,
and I was like, "Dude,
I need a video for like
"my high school,"
and you were like "Done."
And I was like, "Oh."
(Samir and Gary laugh)
- I think it all makes sense.
But I think we're funny.
Like our right hooks
aren't really right hooks.
A lot of it is, but to create,
I think its just trying
to level up the creative with everything.
- When we did a really smart
story for Monday to Monday,
its the most swipe ups
we've gotten in a long time,
which was the texting.
- Because its not a right hook
when it's fuckin' like,
"Here's a cool playlist.
"Do you wanna discover new music?"
I'm paying Boyd a lot of money
to discover new fucking
music for you fuckers.
(Samir and Taylor laugh)
Like seriously!
Like what are we talking about here?
So I think look, but by the way,
I'm pumped, like when I hear
that from Sid, I'm thrilled,
because that means we're
playing at such rarefied air,
that we're creating scrutiny.
I mean think about brand
work, compared to what I do.
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- Their work is like what. (laughs)
- And with right hooks,
I just think about it more on
like setting them off the platform.
That's what I don't like.
I would rather have one story
that gets 13k Swipe Ups,
versus 12 in a row that
are all swiping up,
and they got 1,000 each.
- I understand.
We should, look, I don't,
there's too much process there.
I think you should pick,
and notify them they won,
right on the spot.
This way, you know, like you can send them
somewhere else or to an email,
or to some form, I don't care about that.
But there's too much telephone there,
that cause a swirl, and then
we're letting people down.
- We show the winners,
and just wham go in details,
showing what they're
getting is more exciting,
but also I think showing the others--
- [Gary] Why don't we
show more of the team?
Why don't we show Sophie like,
"Congrats, Ricky Thompson,
Johnny McGee, and this and that,"
like make it more content,
like human content.
Let's pick a different
team member each week,
each day, or whatever,
like, let's do that.
- [Samir] That's a good point.
Like your Instagram stories,
I feel like I don't see
people's faces enough.
- Yeah. More people's faces,
let's keep building up Team GaryVee,
'cause that's just an ownable asset.
Be like, "Hey, it's
Soph from Team GaryVee,
"Congrats Ricky Thompson, Season Mcgoo,
"and 49Pants63. Your books
are coming on the way.
"FirstInLine, y'all."
Alright?
Let's completely switch
to human, rough, raw,
shout out, tag Team GaryVee,
put the handles in there, boom.
Just done. Done. We're
making decisions here.
So this is about--
- [Taylor] How are you feeling with them?
'Cause I've sent you a few options,
and I'm trying to like pick your brain
on like what you want with them.
- It's very subjective time and place.
I think one of the things I struggle with
is the quotes.
Like one of the things
that I'm most fascinated,
like looking at you two
right now, its really funny.
I think one of the great, and
this is great for the vlog,
I think one of the great,
massively misunderstood things,
is how much copy matters.
We're so visual in video
right now and social,
like we grossly underestimate.
I can make every single ad he runs better
if I redid the copy.
I genuinely believe that.
- [Andy] A hundred percent sure?
- A hundred percent sure.
- I think everybody right
now is hungry for it.
- I get it. Honestly, I
want you to help me more.
So I think we're making
too much shit on speck,
but the problem is I'm the bottleneck,
and so like asking you to like
have me do like all the perfect quotes.
And even when I'm approving,
I don't think I'm being
the best filter I can be,
which is why I really wanna
build up Team GaryVee,
'cause one of the things that can be done
is all of that can go,
and then a lot of it can be
like tested in that environment
giving me more data.
I'm trying to, I'll tell you this,
one thing for sure, everybody
should be hyper-aware of,
really for you two most of all,
if I get into that moment that I get into
once every three weeks,
where I just write off four or five BSUs,
or what's happening on Twitter
is the greatest thing that's
happened to us on BSUs.
I'm more motivated now that I have real--
I actually think one
of the best right hooks
is to continue to build my
Twitter through Instagram,
'cause it's motivating
me to do word tweets,
which is then giving us
proxy to the best BSUs.
It's a self-fulfilling prophecy.
So what would I say?
I think that Calvin or
whoever is doing it right now,
trying to pull shit out
of DailyVee is a bad idea.
It's probably a big waste of time.
I feel like none of it's that good.
Like, I feel like I look at nine,
and I'm picking the prettiest
of the ugly ducklings.
Out of context, doesn't work.
- [Andy] Yeah.
- Where as what should happen
is the audience should
be giving us the quotes,
like the comments, one day late,
like no more watch the
video, gimme quotes.
New rule, no more.
- [Andy] 'Cause it
doesn't even fucking work,
'cause you don't like it, and then--
- It doesn't work!
- [Andy] The only reason
we're trying to do it--
- It doesn't work!
- What we should be talking about is
how we should actually be promoting 1205.
- What, brother?
- [Andy] Like new episodes,
'cause that's what I was trying to do,
it's supposed to drive to that.
- I think if we did it, no,
I think with 12 quotes I'm getting,
was the intent to make BSUs, And.
- [Andy] As micro to push that episode.
- And to make more BSU, to both.
- [Andy] Yeah, yeah. But like,
I was thinking in sport of promoting it,
or else, yeah, why is Calvin?
You know what I mean,
'cause there's better
versions of it to me.
- To me the way we do BSUs at its best
is watch people give daps to
something I said in comments.
Fuck, I'd rather people go right now,
and look at videos that
I did four years ago,
look through it, see where
there was love given,
to like, "Oh, that was
fire!", make that clip.
- [Andy] Twitter serves a fun role, too.
Everyone tweeting out
quotes they heard you say.
- Dude I found quotes on tweets
that you said like three years ago.
- What's that?
- I said, why would they tweet something
you said like two years ago or something?
- So much of what I say is evergreen.
- [Andy] Well, that's the crazy shit.
It's like, Anthony went and reserviced
all your top quotes of your last year.
Every one that hit like 110,
besides like the last two,
are always like we just re-did.
- You know what?
This is man, this is the best.
Like just having downtime to be creative.
I think we can do such a fucking amazing
highlight hack tomorrow.
Like if all new shit showed up there,
and it was like three of 'em with like,
some sort of story to it,
like if they all worked
in unison for one day.
Like if all three of them were like black,
and it just said number
one, two, and three,
and you had no idea what the fuck it was.
One, fuck the Patriots, two. (laughs)
So wait a minute, let's
go back into like why--
(background noise drowns out other sounds)
So why don't we make a hardcore
three-and-a-half minute film,
five-and-a-half minute film,
of like what I actually do.
- [Andy] That's Daily
Vee 245, that came out.
- It's not, it's a narrated
by me, in the right zone,
three-and-a-half minute rant.
Fine, so let's A-B test it.
Like to me, something that
starts with the truth,
which is besides everything else,
the thing I pride myself in the most,
is that I'm an operator,
Ninety-eight percent of you
view me as a motivational this,
or that, because the last 18 months,
I've hit painter on content and social.
But did you know, and then like
putting visuals behind that.
And then maybe even like
having people on my team,
and people that work at
Vayner, and clients skip in,
or Babcock saying,
"The thing that freaks me
out the most about Gary
"is that he's actually the
best creative in the house."
Or like, you saying like,
there's so much we can do.
Like new person on the team, and then you.
Client, and then Claude.
But here's the thing that
is the truth about me,
about why I think I'm super successful,
I'm really good at a lot of things.
Sure, I'm not good at certain things,
but I'm really, really good
at a lot of other things,
which is why I'm an enigma.
- [Andy] Or like, the
two things that you're
necessarily the best at involves people.
- Correct.
- [Andy] Yeah it takes a lot
to be really good at that.
- The other thing is in
the top 15 personalities
that are winning right now,
it's what they do full-time.
My biggest truth, like I
genuinely am grateful and happy
because I have life.
Like it's simple as fuck.
Like I don't know how else to say it.
Like I'm not happy that
we're on a private plane.
I don't give a fuck face at all.
I'm happy that like I get to
wake up tomorrow and do shit.
I, secretly, and this has
been hitting me lately,
really wish this was my
life, professionally,
like forget about like my family,
I wish I was 23, we were sitting here,
this wasn't a private plane.
It was like fucking ghetto ass thing.
We ate White Castle all
day, and fucking went.
Like climb the fucking mountain. The game.
I really mean it. I'm really
more interested in it.
Its more fun. This is not more fun.
This is the biggest
confusion. This is less fun.
More fun is zero.
- [Taylor] Thanks, Gary.
- [Sophia] Thank you.
- Now you could always tell this story,
when you flew to Cincinnati.
Bye, guys, have a good night.
(soft acoustic guitar music)